so if it doesn't if you don't lose your
Alpha why do men feel away if their
woman is or no or is on Instagram okay
okay if it doesn't affect your alcohol
why do you care all right all right just
wrong I compare
right new education so if you do open
your opportunity to me I don't I don't
mince my words if you sell your feet
pics to me that's position
um and the men that aren't only fans are
the biggest in the world and they
they've got women thinking that they're
actually in control of something do you
realize how like and this is insane no
this is actually the the mental behind
it Paul yeah because
they cancel the options and women got
mad they actually went on the whole
thing and spoke about oh yeah you know
um this is not equality and and you know
I mean women have the rights and you you
campaign for the right to sell you
pictures it's such a
the concept behind it right whenever you
look in the name is something that women
have built yeah in the world right yeah
which doesn't base it's not based upon
sex or sexuality
what business has been built
what do you mean what business isn't to
name your business a company
that a woman is built in the world
that's contributed to society that was
not met based about sex and beauty
beautification or sexuality
women don't have much Enterprises no no
no no no no no no beyond that no no
women have lots of richest women on the
planet got it through divorce there you
go but the reason you can't think about
it because everything
that makes is based sexuality and
sending it towards men women haven't
built anything you know what I'm trying
to say to you like so yeah I'll just I
was only thinking about it because I was
just like well I was just thinking when
I think of alpha I think of the guys
that women want to bang that's that's
what I think
I'm thinking like do women still want to
bang the guy with a bunch of kids from
all these different hoes yeah yeah
you're limiting it to dating the real
world in the real world dating yeah of
course you can still bang a guy who's
been with lots of hoes you can bang a
future but giving a man the highest
honor you can which is a child yeah they
still sign up but what are the levels of
the women that sign up to a man like
future Ciara was supposed to be a
colleague
Sierra but she left
she left yeah she left ASAP and replaced
it with what kind of man no but two
women don't stick around no but Shadow
babe when she when she had a baby with
future he had how many baby mums already
so this is what I'm trying to say she
didn't care the fact and that's a mating
strategy yeah
that's that's how it like wait yeah wait
okay that's because it was a mating
strategy it's like she got the the kid
with the alpha and then got the beta to
take care of her later that's what she
did uh but I would honestly just say
that it's um great for dating to have
this mentality we're in a post-marriage
society yeah marriage doesn't make sense
for men today I understand that but the
reality is is that you're defining
success and value on how many people
want to have sex with you and really
it's how many people want to invest with
you if you're a woman and how many women
submit to you if you're a man and their
two value is not defined by how many
people want to have sex with you because
a prostitute can have me people having
sex with them I could put on a 3
and many if they're just funny but the
value is defined by men a valuable man
is by how many women of value will
submit to him and women is a valuable
woman uh for women the value is defined
by how many men invest in him and a
valuable woman number one quality a
valuable woman is loyalty because if
she's not loyal to you you're investing
in a woman that is actually belongs to
everybody so any man who can have sex
with millions of women but chooses
promiscuous women all the time he loses
his value your value comes from the
women that submit to you you're telling
me guys shut stopping you're telling me
gangas you're telling me Genghis Khan
yeah was not valuable because he was
[__] everybody no but the women are
they promiscuous he was no they were
loyal to him Genghis Khan
everybody I'm not I'm not debating his
ability to screw but his women
let's talk to the man because man really
pick who's high value it's not the woman
what what makes a guy have value to you
stop high value man
to I think high value money is just
someone that can
protect provide
makes makes his money makes his way in
life
to be honest like
I'll look at myself as a high value man
right six foot plus beard got a great
job business comfortable in life
everything's going well you know what I
mean so I can really pick whichever I go
I want and at the end of the day like
I'll choose which what girl makes sense
so like the thoughts the bad bees
they're for the streets they're for
everyone else you know I mean like I
wouldn't personally pick a girl like
that I'd pick the girl that shows
housewife material qualities you know I
mean so I think it kind of balances
itself out like high value men will meet
their match eventually they'll run
through all the bad bees and the the
crazy thing is yeah is that you get all
these girls right that are bad bees and
they'll be like sixes five sixes sevens
at best but they'll enhance themselves
to make themselves seem like eight or
nine right but then they base their
value of the guys that [__] them yeah
right so do you think it's common for
high value men to sleep with hoes yeah
yeah yeah because because it's easy
because it's easy right it's at the end
of the daylight as a high value man you
have to pick of the bunch you can pick
the Good Girls the bad bad bees whoever
you want you think men lose respect for
other men if they sleep with a lot of
hoes
you're getting more respect because you
know I did what it is like the thing is
it's not easy to actually
sleep with a lot of girls yeah it's not
it's actually very difficult to go out
there and do it you know I mean so do
you have more respect from a man that
sleeps with a bunch of dirty hoes or
just high quality women it doesn't
matter because it's still difficult
regardless like it doesn't matter like
you could be the best looking guy or
more successful you go to a nightclub
you're not guaranteed to be no so I mean
you like you see a lot of guys at the
end of the nightclubs trying to chase
stragglers yeah right because he's not
guaranteed it you're trying to tell the
man what's high value to women but we
don't pick what's high value men pick
what's high value yeah because the men
the men have to pick who is the most
Alpha in the room they pick who leads
Society but um part of being a high
value more a man has to involve who what
woman you have by your side it's
impossible to say you're a high value
man okay when you have a loan
I agree with you on that point so like I
would say if I saw a high value mat like
I wouldn't look at a guy that's married
to her only friends thing yeah and so
you're a high value man because you're a
waste man like why is your girl and only
for
okay I have a question is Drake is Drake
not high value because he had a kid with
an olive I thought he was an idiot for
me getting there getting a a Coinstar
Breakers right but again like babies
happen like I said babies just happened
he wasn't probably he definitely wasn't
planning that it just happened like so
you can't really lose respect for him in
that sense because babies happen but all
I'm saying is if Drake decided to marry
a porn star then I might look at him a
bit like funny you know what I'm saying
if we go like Beyonce or Rihanna like
high value women let's say for example
do you think that if Drake had a baby
with someone like Rihanna or someone
like you think someone's got high value
women I would say yeah yeah I would say
so or Beyonce I would say so give me an
example she's a 32 year old baby mama
yeah but why would she how is she her
value but who would you classify as a
pie value woman 22 year old virgin and
so who would that be there's one on the
show a couple months ago let's take a 22
year old virgin do you think if Drake
had a baby the 22 year old virgin or the
corn star what do you think makes him
more valuable the 22 year old exactly
women does have a role but but I'll be
honest with you Drake can't lose his
value this is like like yeah
you just can't lose his value you can't
lose his value to low value no no no he
just can't lose his
value he needs to basically do what
Kanye done with a 20 20 year old virgin
want to be married to Drake do you think
yes
the difference the difference the
difference is though USA nice girls
don't go for battles
he was saying once a nice girl goes for
a bad boy she's done if she can lock him
down cool is a high value woman a nice
woman is a hive I think a high value
woman has to be chosen by a high value
man I don't think you can just be a high
value Woman by yourself I think women
say that because they're delusional I
could have thought be a high value for
her like a drink
yes she's now high value if if she's
chosen by a high value man just high
value status yeah but cornstar has a
high value to you guys what are you
joking have you not seen how to clean
them up go look at her go look at her
defining value by such no no no no empty
it's not to me basically to me to me
she's the same right yeah but the
society he's gonna clean her up he's
presenting he's now he's put her back to
the Instagram world and she's so Marvel
she doesn't she's now higher value no no
no no no no no to the world she's
representing her now and now she's on
Instagram and she's doing art things
which is good
what he's done to her now she's like she
works in Galleries and she does oh and
she does these things you know what it
is money and status changed everything
in both sides like so as for a man if
you've got higher value High status and
you got money then all the rules don't
apply to you and it's the same with
women like you see like The City girls
all these women online they're the ones
that are promoting the most ratchet
Behavior yeah but they will still
probably settle down and marry someone
but the difference is is that them women
have money and Status so they can kind
of get away with it to an extent whereas
the women that want to be like them they
don't have the same money or status so
they can't act the same Japanese I just
don't think it's true that nice girls
don't go for guys just because they
picked a bad girl at one point
I don't I don't think Drake is gonna
have any problems do you think that when
a drake say for example a drake takes a
a porn star a porn star story um does he
raise a Coinstar status or does she
decrease his status because to me she
decreases his status he doesn't raise
hers because nothing can raise us no
he's raised hers what
I agree that a bad woman can lower it
guys absolutely I agree with you I I
think that a bad woman can lower a guy's
status but I don't think it makes him
not Alpha but that's my whole point like
my whole life
no the point is that women want to screw
him and why do they want to screw him
because he has money status power
whatever it is defining Alpha by ability
to have sex a dildo can have sex but
that's not her so dude yeah but the
point is exactly people that have sex
doesn't mean Power Respect the ability
to Alpha is not defined by the ability
to have sex it's the ability to have
women submit okay okay I hear okay I
hear immensely okay cool I hear I hear I
hear where you're going with it yeah
yeah I hear it but in reality it's not
going to be that way I hear it I hear
everything that you're saying and to be
classes out
but it will not diminish straight status
and it will not diminish any man of his
status someone like me might look at
that and say oh that's an L I wouldn't
do that but who the hell am I and what
the hell do I matter even someone of
this even another rappers you saw um
what's his name Pusha T push your teeth
literally
finished Drake here but it didn't do
nothing to drink success Pusha T
literally finished straight embarrass
them about the story of added on let
everyone know about the kid about his
Adidas still mess up the Adidas roll out
but what did it do to Drake in the end
all Drake did was present clean up the
woman bring out his kid and started
doing Daddy in actual fact we oh
everything don't clean up women look you
can't clean up women but the thing is
you're also forgetting the fact that
we're in a different Society so yeah in
this particular Western Society
yeah I think America is the worst place
because I don't think America is a real
place
that's been cleaned up I don't think
there's a single woman who's past hasn't
defined her future
Kardashian she's still not cleaned up
she's still she's still not for the
streets no way come on Kim Kardashian is
not somebody okay okay
and yet her sex tape still gets talked
about and she's got little kids that
will see it
okay okay
but the point with the part are you
married no I'm not married okay so the
point is her results are still better
than me and you yeah she got she got
three high-value proposals three not one
not two three but so so so we could say
we could [__] under all we want yeah but
her results are better than ours that's
because you're defining results by right
if the men if the men pick you the high
value men it has to be the level of men
and also your parenting to find out now
if your children can see you naked
having sex with another man you can
never be a high value woman no but
you're pushing the ball out again
kick him gets a bladder again because
money and status but the reality is if
your children can watch you have sex you
are not a valuable woman I I I agree you
should not pick a girl that that has a
sex tape on the internet I'm with you
I'm with you I'm I'm the width I'm with
you and I don't think I'm with you but
but if you're a high value a high value
woman is picked by a high value man and
she was picked more than once so again
it was how do we Define a high value man
I don't know what you know actually
actually I'm gonna send Blessing the
clip let's hold on hold on let's you
don't think he's insane
why he's a billionaire so so like I
think you can't clean up I stand by that
you can't clean up anything but look a
high volume because look at the tree
look at it like let's take Kim for
example if you try and clean up a woman
especially in this day and age your kids
can still see that mother doing the most
you can't please yeah I agree I agree it
lowers your status as a guy like you can
have a girl that embarrasses you but I
just I just don't think he's not out
like Drake is not Alpha because he
screwed a porn star his child can watch
his mom the mother
we're not but you can't see the thing
about us men we can see us men can pick
the alphas right because when we're in a
room we can literally put ourselves into
um into an older pecking order we don't
need women to do that you women argue
about stuff us men we can literally go
in the room and we can work it I would
argue with you wait hold on hold on hold
on a second yeah we can work it out
that's why women always argue men we
already know that's what when it comes
down to an argument Movement we won't
argue for more than 60 seconds because
after 60 seconds we're about to go into
blows because men we don't like to do
those type of stuff we're gonna say what
you saying what
[Music]
I think I even had Kevin Samuel talk
about this one so if you actually we're
gonna we're gonna pull up like Kevin
Samuels because yeah Kevin Samuel said
you know your woman does Define you
though yeah I mean he would say that a
woman defines you because he was talking
once about how he went to some event
with the
no I just think your choice definitely
removes your Alpha if you choose
promiscuous Elon Musk not a high value
man that's why I said
can we just clarify how we're defining
how about because for me the protection
is as much as a provision you guys are
just focusing on provision for me
protection and provision is the same
thing when it comes to masculinity it
has to be the same level if you can't
protect your children and your wife
you're not high value no matter how much
money you got and if your children can
access pictures of their mom having sex
with other men you haven't protected
that child if the if your wife can go
have sex with other men or put her body
up father when you're not protecting
your woman so the protection is as
valuable as a provision yes yeah but you
I will look at you different but I
wouldn't it wouldn't change the fact if
you're successful Success is Not can I
say something though I could be okay
it's all the key so okay so when we're
talking about high value men we're
talking about men that will earn over
six figures have done it consistent for
over five years we're talking about
um blessing you're gonna play it oh
you're gonna you're gonna yeah just um
it's from this front
because it goes okay however because I
think we're talking about Alpha and
we're talking about high value men and I
think those are different yeah I think
it's getting a conference I think it's
getting it well I would imagine it's
relatively similar before he has a woman
yeah and that's a fact
but we could be high value well imagine
this we get into a fight and because
because you um you're not in you know
you're not with your baby mum no more
you knock me out man is saying he's not
Alpha I'm with my missing so I'm Alpha I
just got knocked out by a man that man
that's not with his girl he's definitely
Alpha
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible